[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA DENE EARLEY-CHA:
Hi, everyone.
My name is Jessica
Dene Earley-Cha,
and I'm a Developer Advocate
for the Google Assistant.
Today, I'm going to walk
you through the latest
version of the actions on Google
Console, which makes developing
faster and easier than ever.
When you create
actions, you can now
choose from several categories.
Depending on the
action type you select,
your workflow will change.
For each category, you'll
get specific guidance
across stages of
development-- setup,
build, test,
deploy, and measure.
One of the first things
you want to do for setup
is to give your actions
an invocation name.
Choose a simple but unique name.
You want users to easily
invoke your actions.
Now, you can go ahead
and build your action.
Start by defining
the intents you'll
want your user to be able to do.
You'll also need to
find fulfillments--
how your action responds
to your users' requests.
One of our fulfillment
types is conversation.
That could be created with
Dialogflow Dialogflow is
a tool that uses AI
and natural language
processing to understand
the user, which
then triggers your action.
The console pulls from
the Dialogflow project,
so you could see
what you have set up.
As you're inputting all of
your intents and fulfillments,
you can test your
actions in the simulator.
Make sure to test it on
different service types,
like audio only speakers and
mobile devices, which have
audio and visual capabilities.
You'll be able to see the
JSON requests and responses
from actions on Google
to your action, as well
as logs and errors.
You can even test your action
on your personal devices
that are linked to your
same Google account.
Now that you've
tested your action
and have all the
functionality you want,
you can start the
deployment process.
All you need to do is add
metadata to your action.
Once that's done,
submit your action
in for the review process.
After your pass' review,
it's available to all users,
or you could use our
alpha and beta releases
to try out your actions
with a smaller group.
Once the actions are live,
it's time to measure.
You can do this with
our analytics tool.
There, you can see usage,
errors, and discovery data.
So that was a quick demo of
the actions on Google Console.
You can find out
more about Actions
on Google by checking
out the docs in the link
in the description below.
We also have a Google
Plus community,
so you can ask your questions
and share your ideas
with everyone.
I'm Jessica Dene Earley-Cha.
Thanks for watching.
And I look forward to
seeing what you build.